il est fait il est 7h il est
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
sujet de avec les yeux de Morgane le
sujet conduire sa vie que vous ayez
l'âme de Oui-Oui dans sa belle voiture
plutôt celle d'un pilote de Formule 1
que vous soyez plutôt zen ou inventif
sur les jurons ce sujet est fait pour
vous alors quel changement lié au
passage du permis quand on a un handicap
la réponse tout de suite avec Nicolas et
Clara
[Musique]
tout de suite regardons le reportage de
tv78 et on retrouve les invités en
plateau juste après
[Musique]
et voilà là j'ai un cercle au niveau du
volant qui permet d'accélérer et là sur
le côté j'ai le frein l'adaptation est
quand même assez cher parce qu'en
fonction du handicap on a en fonction
des besoins qu'on va avoir ça peut être
hyper onéreux
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup d'organisations si je
veux prendre les transports en commun
par exemple il faut appeler
24h48 heures à l'avance donc ça c'est
pas des plus pratiques en termes de
spontanéité de rester les courses j'ai
fini par acheter une voiture qui me
laisse une plus grande liberté une plus
grande autonomie j'ai dû repasser une
adaptation en tant que personne en
situation de handicap c'est vraiment pas
très compliqué étant donné qu'on a déjà
le code et qu'on a déjà le permis en
fait on est juste une adaptation au
volant avec lesquelles on apprend à
conduire et ensuite on passe une espèce
de réadaptation avec lequel enfin durant
lequel en fait on fait c'est à dire 10
20 minutes dans lequel on fait le tour
du pâté de maison on voit si on est à
l'aise avec la conduite sur avec les
mains
[Musique]
voilà le plus difficile maintenant c'est
de tourner ce qu'il faut réussir à
tourner tout en accélérant on se verrait
c'est toute une histoire vous voyez
effectivement c'est assez compliqué
alors dans les centres commerciaux il y
a beaucoup de place donc ça c'est assez
chouette et après les places handicapées
finalement
elles se font assez rares
[Musique]
du coup il faut réussir à être
suffisamment loin de la voiture
pour pouvoir sortir le fauteuil
[Musique]
bonjour Nicolas et bonjour Clara
merci à tous les deux d'être là pour ce
beau sujet autour de la conduite une
grande étape qui nous concerne tous pour
le coup alors déjà Clara donc toi tu as
passé ton permis il y a peu c'est ça oui
c'est ça OK et donc qu'est-ce qui t'a
amené à vouloir passer ce permis et
peut-être à avoir besoin d'adaptation
par la suite bah j'ai passé permis parce
que j'avais besoin d'acquérir d'acquérir
ma propre autonomie parce qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas parce qu'on est
atteint d'un handicap qu'on ne peut pas
faire les choses comme tout le monde on
va avoir plus de difficultés ça c'est
sûr mais ça va pas nous en empêcher et
moi j'en avais besoin autant pour ma vie
personnelle et également pour ma vie
professionnelle
il y avait plusieurs enjeux derrière
donc moi bah j'étais obligé de le passer
en adapter parce que j'ai un handicap
donc de naissance et je suis atteinte
donc d'une infirmité motrice cérébrale
ça touche bah surtout mes jambes en fait
j'ai les muscles qui sont très raides et
donc moi ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'au
niveau des pédales je ne pouvais pas
faire le geste nécessaire qu'il fallait
donc du coup bah j'ai ces adaptations là
qui ont été mis en place pour le permis
tout à fait on va y revenir un petit peu
après mais ouais effectivement donc des
adaptations qui peuvent vraiment t'aider
au quotidien et je rebondis donc avec
toi Nicolas donc tu es moniteur
d'auto-école c'est ça tout à fait
d'accord et donc tu es un peu spécialisé
sur dans l'accompagnement oui
effectivement je suis enseignant de la
conduite depuis 16 ans et je suis
responsable de la formation des
personnes en situation de handicap
depuis maintenant trois ans
donc j'imagine que effectivement comme
disait Clara il y a des adaptations
spécifiques aussi dans la formation de
personnes en situation de handicap
qu'est-ce qui compose un petit peu ton
quotidien de moniteur et les adaptations
qui vont avec alors il existe pléthore
d'aménagement parce qu'il existe
pléthore d'handicap donc chaque handicap
à son aménagement
nous avons nous une voiture qui est
aménagée pour des handicaps on va dire
simple des handicap moteur assez simple
nous avions nous avons parlons un
pédalier inversé donc l'accélérateur se
trouve à gauche pour les personnes qui
n'ont plus d'usage de leur jambe droite
ça c'est la première des choses on a
donc une boule multifonction clipsable à
gauche ou à droite du volant pour
permettre donc aux personnes qui nous
usage que d'un bras de tourner le volant
et de mettre les clignotants les
accessoires qui vont avec et nous avons
également donc comme pour Clara un
accélérateur à main droite donc style
gâchette de moto donc une poignée de
moto que l'on tourne pour avancer et que
l'on pousse pour freiner voilà c'est
vrai on se rend pas forcément en compte
de tout ce qui est faisable mais
finalement il y a plein plein
d'alternatives pour conduire en fait
tout à fait effectivement là il y a
plein d'alternatives plein
d'aménagements différents nous on a fait
le choix donc d'une gâchette de moto
mais il existe aussi donc d'autres
systèmes pour accélérer comme le cercle
volant c'est je pense au plus connu
nous avons pas fait ce choix là parce
que nous on a fait le choix de la
simplicité pour nos élèves pour nos
apprenants
et Clara pour toutes ces adaptations
est-ce que tu avais entendu parler de ce
type d'aménagement avant de tester à
l'auto-école où tu as vraiment découvert
sur place non non j'ai vraiment
découvert sur place oui c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être difficile de trouver des
informations je sais pas après je me
rends pas forcément compte comment
s'orient justement quand on veut passer
le permis et que moi j'ai eu des
complications à trouver une auto-école
déjà et après il faut donc on ait une
visite médicale avec un médecin agréé de
la préfecture ce qui est aussi compliqué
enfin moi ça a été compliqué parce que
ça s'est fait en période du covid et une
fois qu'on nous valide les adaptations
j'ai pris donc rendez-vous à
l'auto-école donc il y a le dossier
d'inscription qui s'est fait et puis par
la suite j'ai passé mon code et puis bah
après la conduite tout à fait était tu
étais dans quel état d'esprit super
motivé un peu stressé ça pas forcément
motivé à passer le permis donc au début
ça allait mais au fur et à mesure j'ai
commencé à prendre peur et bah justement
du aussi un moment de confiance en moi
que j'ai
tu es compliqué mais
ça a été compliqué mais ça c'est fait
mais finalement tu as réussi la preuve
d'accord et Nicolas comment on fait pour
accompagner justement ces situations de
stress or chez tout le monde pour le
coup mais ça se passe comment on fait
pour rassurer ou pour aider les élèves à
prendre conscience
ça dépend de l'élève parce que donc
chaque élève fonctionne différemment
certains élèves on va dans leur sens en
leur disant voilà que tout va bien se
passer qu'effectivement c'est normal
d'avoir peur d'autres où il faut être un
petit peu plus on va dire moins ce coin
voilà parce qu'il y a des personnes qui
qui malgré leur motivation sont toujours
on va dire dans la peur ce qui était le
cas de Clara
non ça se finit toujours bien il faut il
faut s'adapter à chaque élève le métier
d'enseignant c'est s'adapter avant tout
encore de l'adaptation c'est vrai c'est
ça et dans ton cas petite question je
sais pas est-ce que tu te souviens un
petit peu toi dans quel état d'esprit tu
étais lorsque tu as passé ton permis
oui je me souviens très bien de mes
premières leçons de conduite de
certaines leçons avec mon enseignante de
l'époque
j'étais jeune j'ai fait la conduite
accompagnée j'étais très motivé j'avais
très envie d'apprendre la conduire une
voiture et je conduisais déjà alors pas
sur les routes mais un petit peu en
dehors sur des chemins ou avec ma maman
effectivement elle me laissait donc le
volant les pédales donc j'avais quelques
notions j'étais très intéressé depuis
très longtemps par la conduite c'est une
histoire de famille la conduite on aime
beaucoup voilà une vraie passion
derrière et aujourd'hui toi Clara la
conduite c'est quelque chose qui te
plaît vraiment
bah si ça me plaît vraiment je sais pas
mais je sais que
ça me plaît forcément minimum sinon
permis je leur ai passé plus que ça et
puis je sais très bien enfin ça va me
permettre de moi de pouvoir avoir ma
liberté et de plus dépendre de personne
c'est ça que j'allais te demander au
delà du côté ça te plaît ça te plaît pas
c'était un petit peu est-ce que vraiment
ça change ta vie quelque part le permis
oui ça me change ma vie surtout que moi
j'habite en campagne donc j'ai pas de
transport
qui sont à côté et vu que je pars en
alternance au mois de septembre j'ai
forcément besoin de ma voiture bah pour
aller sur mon lieu de l'entreprise même
si j'ai encore la prise du taxi qui se
fera mais simplement pour aller donc à
vitesse de tour pour m'éviter de faire
trop de route et de fatiguer bah plus
rapidement il y a plein de trucs
intéressants dans ce que tu viens de
dire c'est que quelque part aussi le
permis de ce que je comprends ça peut
pas un petit peu à la fatigue habilité
dans les déplacements en fait oui
parce que du coup je me déplaçais bah
forcément avec la marche et j'ai déjà
des difficultés donc pour marcher je
vais peiner plus facilement et avec le
permis je vais forcément faire moins
d'efforts donc je vais avoir plus
d'énergie quand je serai à l'école ou
quand je serai sur mon lieu d'entreprise
ou même en dehors si je vais voir de la
famille ou autre oui c'est plus simple
plutôt effectivement que de passer sans
doute des heures dans des transports et
de fatiguer plus ou d'être sur une
station seulement debout seulement
assise ouais ça doit être plus simple de
pouvoir gérer sur des temps courts comme
ça
c'est très effectivement ça c'est super
intéressant et en termes d'autonomie
on sent qu'il y a de vrais enjeux
derrière mais qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez donc l'un comme l'autre de cette
grande importance du permis et de
l'enjeu qui derrière
parce que enfin ce que je veux dire en
fait de ce que je comprends c'est que
effectivement ça peut être peut-être un
tremplin vers les études mais vers le
travail finalement de passer son permis
y compris avec un handicap tu en penses
quoi
bah oui c'est sûr et puis
malheureusement il y a très peu
d'auto-école qui sont qui sont adaptés
pour les personnes situations de
handicap notamment l'auto-école de la
gare c'est la seule auto-école en
indre-et-loir
ah oui alors moi je connais pas
forcément effectivement les chiffres
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait assez
peu d'auto-école qui proposait en fait
voilà de la conduite adaptée et comment
ça s'explique Saint-Nicolas
ça s'explique parce que par le fait que
le coût du de l'aménagement et supporter
en totalité par l'école de conduite
aucune aide de l'État aucune aide du
département
et donc c'est un coût assez élevé parce
qu'il faut donc acheter ou louer la
voiture et puis ensuite effectuer tous
les aménagements et donc toutes les
écoles de conduite ne peuvent pas se le
permettre
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a très
peu d'auto-écoles actuellement nous
sommes les seuls en Eure-et-Loir après
donc les auto-écoles les plus proches
c'est LE MANS Orléans ou région
parisienne donc effectivement ça fait un
peu loin on est déjà pour Clara qui
habite en campagne elle mettait du temps
à venir nous voir donc elle mettra
encore plus de temps pour aller à
Orléans un moment ah oui il y a assez
peu d'alternatives sinon heureusement du
coup que vous êtes là
l'auto-école de la gare mais ouais
effectivement on comprend qu'il y a très
peu d'aide derrière et comment ça se
passe donc pour aménager un véhicule une
fois qu'on a dit que c'était assez frais
il y a beaucoup de démarches où il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui proposent ces
adaptations pas du tout alors il y a
quelques entreprises il y a quelques
antennes en Eure-et-Loir nous on a fait
le choix d'aller à Rouen
chez un
équipementier qui qui est très réputé
qui a donc aménagé les véhicules des
anciennes écoles de conduite qui
proposait cette activité donc nous on a
poursuivi avec eux et donc on envoie
également tous nos élèves là-bas on sait
qu'ils sont fiables donc voilà il
propose donc plein de solutions
donc on en voit tous nos élèves et on
fait toujours réparer notre voiture
là-bas également d'accord
ah oui effectivement faut savoir
vraiment vers qui se tourner tout de
suite quelque part on est là aussi
on a un rôle de conseils parce que
effectivement c'est un conseil de les
envoyer chez eux après ils font bien
bien ce qu'ils veulent mais voilà
généralement la on va dire que 95% des
élèves que j'ai conseillé sont allés
voir directement donc l'entreprise dont
je leur ai parlé
mais c'est bien d'avoir justement oui
les pistes tout de suite tout à fait et
savoir comment réagir et toi ça s'est
passé comment Clara du coup pour pouvoir
aménager ton véhicule c'est très
compliqué j'ai le dossier donc à la MDA
qui est ouverte film mois de décembre
donc bah il y a des papiers envoyés donc
notamment le 2 un de ces médicaments à
faire compléter par le médecin traitant
après donc là on m'a demandé donc deux
devis donc il y a un devis donc de Rouen
et un autre de Coignières et donc du
coup bah là tout est renvoyé et on
attend on attend une réponse sachant
qu'on l'a on les a quand même relancé
pas mal de fois pour leur dire que
c'était quand même assez
urgent je suis passé aussi par
l'ergothérapeute parce qu'ils ont des
critères bien spécifiques donc pour
l'achat du véhicule il faut une voiture
moins de 10 ans moins de 150000 km en
automatique ce qui est très compliqué à
trouver aussi ah oui il y a d'autres
étapes finalement ensuite pour pouvoir
avoir un véhicule
ok mais alors malgré toutes ces étapes
et le fait que effectivement ça a l'air
je comprends assez compliqué comment tu
pourrais rassurer peut-être d'autres
jeunes en situation de handicap qui ont
envie de passer le permis et que ça
inquiète parce que toi tu as quand même
réussi et voilà en tout cas tu es dans
les démarches et donc comment tu
pourrais les rassurer un petit peu
ce qui soit inquiet c'est normal mais
s'ils ont vraiment l'envie et qu'ils ont
la motivation il faut pas qu'ils se
prenne à leur handicap et se dire que
ils sont en situation de handicap ils
peuvent pas passer le permis parce qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
même si la MDA ça prend du temps ça va
se faire un moment donné on a quand même
la chance d'avoir une partie des
équipements qui nous sont financés sur
le véhicule malgré que le véhicule coûte
plus cher
[Musique]
on va dire lourde et le coût financier
de telles aménagements est très très
lourd également oui bien sûr mais on se
rend compte qu'il y a un côté un peu
high-tech donc on fait ça et ça a
presque l'air futuriste en fait c'est
d'actualité mais ça a l'air très
futuriste finalement oui on va bientôt
finir par conduire au son de la voix
finalement c'est ça c'est ça même moi je
pourrais non non c'est une blague
je suis assez éloignée de l'univers de
la conduite mais aujourd'hui avec les
véhicules aussi autonomes quelque part
on peut imaginer qu'il y a encore plus
de solutions à l'avenir quel que soit la
pathologie qu'on est en fait bien sûr
quelque part et dans les solutions
potentielles au-delà de la technologie
et ce que il pourrait y avoir d'autres
solutions notamment peut-être pour aider
aussi les auto-écoles à proposer
davantage de système de conduite adapté
mais il faudrait que que l'État prenne
en charge une partie des aménagements
encourage aussi parce qu'on n'est pas
forcément encouragé on nous a proposé de
faire donc enfin la formation des
personnes en situation de handicap ma
responsable a accepté mais si elle
n'avait pas accepté alors d'aujourd'hui
il n'y aurait pas d'école de conduite en
Eure-et-Loir proposant cette activité
donc lorsqu'il faudrait c'est vraiment
qui est plus d'accompagnement de la part
des services de l'État
et ça permettrait donc aux écoles de
conduite de proposer donc davantage de
formation avec des véhicules
ayant différents aménagements pour
essayer donc
de former deux personnes handicapées de
pouvoir accompagner effectivement plus
de profil et plus d'élèves quelque part
oui il faudra un travail d'équipe en
fait en amont qui est vraiment une
réflexion peut-être plus globale de ce
que je comprends
c'est vrai et toujours la dessus
peut-être juste une ou deux une ou deux
années de
oui c'est ça un ou deux éléments
positifs je commence par toi Nicolas
peut-être est-ce que tu te souviens de
réaction qui t'ont un peu marqué de la
part des lèvres en situation de handicap
qui aurait eu leur permis
alors
on a eu tellement peut-être c'est pas
facile de sélectionner effectivement il
y en a eu pas mal notamment si une élève
que j'ai formé de A à Z qui donc a été
victime d'une chute de cheval à 14 ans
qui est resté donc paraplégique
non cet élève là j'ai eu un plaisir
incommensurable à la forme et à
l'accompagner elle était forte
elle avait envie elle était motivée et
je pense que quand elle a passé son
permis j'étais plus stressé qu'elle
et j'ai même on va dire verser une
petite larme quand même quand elle l'a
eu
de l'émotion de la satisfaction de la
fierté parce que c'est
important pour moi d'accompagner donc
les élèves en situation de handicap même
si donc les moments parfois sont un peu
difficiles mais voilà c'est vraiment une
satisfaction personnelle
d'accord et donc motivation satisfaction
fierté et je me tourne vers toi très
rapidement que la race que tu veux
ajouter quelque chose est-ce que tu as
quelque chose à dire peut-être sur je
sais pas les réactions de ton entourage
quand tu as eu ton permis et parce que
l'émission va bien dosage fait
ils étaient très contents
j'avais fait croire à ma mère que je
l'avais pas eu mais ah oui tu lui as
fait une blague d'accord elle est tombée
dedans c'est vrai tout de suite mais
normalement ils étaient forcément bah
très content parce qu'il voit que malgré
le handicap je m'en sors que ce soit
pour le permis que ce soit encore pour
les études et que même s'il y a des
moments plus compliqués que d'autres que
j'ai forcément envie de lâcher que j'ai
que j'ai jamais lâché que je lâcherai
pas mais tu as réussi et ça doit être
une fierté effectivement pour d'accord
et ben sur cette notion de blague et de
fierté juste après merci à toi Clara
merci beaucoup Nicolas l'émission est
déjà finie alors merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces informations ça m'a appris
beaucoup de choses à moi qui suis très
éloignée de la conduite j'espère que ce
sera pareil pour les personnes qui ont
regardé merci à vous encore une fois
c'est déjà la fin de ce sujet conduire
sa vie de avec les yeux de Morgane vous
pourrez le retrouver bien sûr en
intégralité ainsi que toute son
actualité sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'émission je vous dis à très bientôt
avec les yeux de Morgane
[Musique]